hello the u.n general assembly has voted
to suspend russia from the u.n human
rights council 93 countries backed the
suspension with 24 opposed 58 countries
abstained russia is the second country
to be removed from the human rights
council after libya had its membership
stripped in 2011. let's go live to
christmas illumi at the united nations
to talk us through
some of the numbers and the reaction
that has been coming in
yes well this was the latest attempt to
isolate russia on the international
stage and hold them accountable for
uh the atrocities that have been
unfolding in ukraine
and the general assembly succeeded in
suspending russia from the human rights
council but perhaps
not isolating them as much as ukraine's
backers would have liked we had a vote
where the u.s was calling
calling out russia called for this vote
accusing them of war crimes
saying it was hypocrisy for them to be
on the rights council
russia
for its part described it as an attempt
to destroy the human rights architecture
at the united nations and we know they
lobbied
member states very hard before this vote
we've seen copies of correspondence
where
countries were warned that it would be
considered a
an unfriendly gesture if they
voted against russia here uh at the end
of the day 93 countries voted in favor
of suspending russia 24 were against 58
abstained
the united states hails that as a
success and holding russia accountable
russia says
it's going to quit anyways they don't
care anymore they announce that they're
quitting now so uh at the end of the day
russia was removed from this council but
again perhaps not as isolated as
ukraine's backers would have liked okay
thank you so much kristin salumi
reporting from the united nations
ukraine is urging nato members to step
up weapons supplies quickly as it
prepares for a russian offensive in the
east its foreign minister dimitro caleb
has been holding talks with nato foreign
ministers in brussels local authorities
in the eastern lohan's region have urged
all civilians to leave immediately
either you help us now
and i'm speaking about days not weeks
or
your help will come too late
and
many people will die
many civilians will lose their homes
many villages will be destroyed
exactly because this help came too late
weapons are like money they like they
love silence
and
i will not be in a position to go into
details
but
let me put it this way i have no doubts
that ukraine
will have
weapons necessary to fight
the question is the timeline
well the head of nato says allies have
agreed to strengthen support for ukraine
including the delivery of a wide range
of weapons it follows a two-day meeting
of nato foreign ministers in brussels
allies are providing a wide range of
different weapon systems
both
soviet era systems but also modern
equipment
and i think that this distinction
between offensive and defensive is a bit
strange
because we speak about providing weapons
to a country which is defending itself
and and self-defense is a right which is
enshrined in the eu in charter so
everything ukraine does
with the support from nato allies is
defensive
well u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken says washington will not let
anything stand in the way of sending
more arms to ukraine
we have been
individually as the united states and
collectively as
partners more than 30 countries
providing to ukraine
the the weapons and systems that
we believe
it can use most effectively
and that it needs
to push back against russian aggression
and we're not going to let anything
stand in the way of getting ukrainians
what they need and what we believe can
be effective so
we're looking across the board right now
not only at what we've provided and
continue to provide
but whether there are additional
systems that would make a difference
stavasan has more from brussels
lincoln makes clear the balancing act
that nato countries have been going
through in the last couple of days he
gave some very detailed and also
gruesome accounts of alleged war crimes
and atrocities committed in ukraine
basically giving
a clear message that there was a moral
responsibility felt
by nato to do more for ukraine to send
more military support but uh cutting
short of of being short of actually
sending troops to ukraine and also
sending planes to ukraine because that
could be seen by russia as getting a
clear involvement of nato in the war
with ukraine and could possibly cause a
war between russia and nato so basically
the nato countries have stepped up their
efforts but have not gone
in a total shift
aiding ukraine with troops and planes
and that's why he had a long list of
sanctions of
the all kinds of measures that the
united states is now imposing on russia
and that has been of course this very
delicate balancing act that we've seen
here in brussels in the last couple of
days
rescue workers in ukraine are searching
under the rubble of apartment blocks
destroyed by russian forces it's feared
people could still be trapped under the
debris in borodyanka about 60 kilometers
from the capital kiev residents say they
were threatened by russian forces at
gunpoint for trying to rescue survivors
ukrainian troops regained control of the
town a week ago
well residents of the nearby town abucha
have spoken of the trauma they suffered
under russian bombardment many spent
more than a month in basements or
shelters to escape the fighting people
are now beginning to venture out to
survey the damage and reunite with their
families and ukrainian soldiers are
checking for mines and other explosives
we were in the basement for 35 days
there was shelling all the time
sometimes there was no water sometimes
there was no food there was no light all
the time there was no information phones
didn't work there were shots all the
time
the children were cold i hugged them all
the time i told them that everything
would be fine and ukrainian soldiers
would come i explained to them how to
fall how to run how to defend
ukrainian authorities are working to
identify hundreds of bodies found in
bucha and other towns after russian
troops withdrew
some of the bodies are in a mass grave
near a church the un's humanitarian
chief martin griffiths traveled to bucha
to visit a burial site
ukraine has blamed the killings on
russian troops allegations moscow denies
well earlier i spoke to the un
humanitarian chief martin griffiths and
he described what he saw in bucha
i had that
unpleasant and awful privilege
as you say going to bucha today to see
the worst of what people can do
to people and i
i was taken to a mass grave
in the courtyard of a church
this is a grave where
local people had brought
apparently up to 280
bodies of dead people
from around bukhar
to this grave so they could at least
have somewhere
where they could be provisionally buried
um
and when we were there we saw these
bodies
in these graves and they're now being
exhumed brought out for forensic
examination
to find out who killed these people
and
you know one of the things that came to
my mind of course was
if you're a
close relative of any of those 280
people you would want
a decent burial
in this tragic circumstance and we're
still waiting for it
and we're still waiting
for the results
of an
investigation to see exactly who did
these terrible things who should be held
accountable
my secretary general antonio contes has
of course called for an investigation
we think that's totally right i'm glad
that local authorities are also
launching their own we need the truth
and we need to urgently and we need the
people of bucha to have some kind of
closure
after these terrible incidents in the
last weeks